LOURNS?
>> THANKS, CARLASM ISREAL'S
FIGHT TO PROTECT ITS BORDER
RAISING FIERCE OF OUR OWN AT OUR
BORDER.
MEMO BY THE DAILY CALLER IN SAN
DIEGO WARNS INDIVIDUALS INPYRED
BY REFER REACTING TO THE HAMAS
CONFLICT MAY ATTEMPT TO TRAVEL
TO FROM THE AREA OF HOSTILITIES
IN THE MEAT VIA ACROSS THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
COME A RECORD NUMBER OF SUSPECTS
TRIED ENTER THE COUNTRY.
FORMER ICE DIRECTOR JOINS US
NOW.
YOU KNOW TOM AS PEOPLE ARE
PRAYING FOR OUR FRIEND IN ISREAL
AND SEEING THE CONFLICT THE
QUESTION I GET WHEN I TALK TO
AMERICANS ARE, ARE THOSE PEOPLE
THAT THREATEN ISREALI HERE AT
HOME?
YOU SAY WHAT?
>> I SAY ABSOLUTELY.
I WROTE ANOM ED IN JUNE OF 2020.
I SAID IF JOE BIDEN BECOMES
PRESIDENT WE LOSE THE BORDER
WHEN YOU LOSE THE BORDER WHEN
THE BORDER PRINCIPLE IS SO
OVERWHELMS MOST ARE NOT ON
PATROL THEY ARE DEALING WITH
SELF INBEING CONFLICTED
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS WHEN
FENTANYL AND SEX TRAFFICKING SKY
ROCKET AND TERRORISTS USE THAT
BERREDTORY GET IN THIS COUNTRY.
LEFT MONTH 18 IN I MONT.
4 YEARS TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WE
HAD 47 IN 4 YEARS SINCE BIDEN
TAKEN THE WHITE HOUSE 272 WE
HAVE 14 IN 4 YEARS, THIS IS THE
BIG OF INITIAL SECURITY FAILURE
I SEEN SINCE 911 THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE -- THOSE OTHER ONES
THEY CAUGHT.
1.7 MILLION GOT AWAYS.
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW BORDER
PATROL ARREST FROM 171 COUNT
ROWS SOME ARE EXPERIENCESHIP OF
TERROR.
THAN I RESTED 272.
IF YOU DON'T THINK THAT A SINGLE
ONE OF THIS 1.7 MILLION DID IN
THE COME HERE TO DO US HARM FROM
I COUNTRY SPONSORING TERRORISM
YOU ARE IGNORING THE DATA I KNOW
INSPECT MY HEART BASED ON 3
DECADES OF DOING THIS.
MORE CROSSED OUR BORDER I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY SOME WILL FIND OUT
AND AT THIS TIME BE A BAD DAY
FOR AMERICA.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE BOARD AND
PROTESTS ALL OVER NOW.
PEOPLE ARE SCREAMING DEATH TO
AMERICA.
OPEN JIHAD SOMEONE QUESTIONED ME
WHY SATURDAY AMERICAN PRESS IS
HERE AS IF AMERICA IS A FOREIGN
COUNTRY.
SOMEONE IN PATROL AND HOME LAND
SCOUR FOR OVER 30 YEARS, ARE YOU
CONCERNED NOW THAT YOU SEE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY NOT JUST AT
THE BORDER BUT THE PROTESTS IN
I'M CONCERNED FROM A COUPLE OF
ASPECTS.
THE SYMPATHIZERS ARE SUPPORTING
HAMAS THE TERRORISTS OF THE
COUNTRY AND SYMPATHIZERS HERE
THEY CAN BE TALKED TO DOING
MANAGE STUPID AND HARMING THE
COUNTRY.
FOR THE PEOPLE PROTESTING ON A
VIS THEY CAME FROM THE COUNTRY
AND WE TOOK THEM IN AND NAMED
THEM PART OF THE COUNTRY IF THEY
ATTACK THE UNITED STATES LOOK AT
ACTION DO TO DEPORT THEM AND
RILL IS DOING A GREAT JOB YOU
CAN'T SAY THINGS IT IS TOO
AWFUL.
TOO DRAMATIC FOR BEING ON
NATIONAL TV I THINK WE NEED TO
SAY THESE THINGS WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT THE THINGS HAD MAS DID AND
THE INHUMIN THINGS TO THE
ISIRRELEVANT PEOPLE TO LET
AMERICANS KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
THERE I THINK THIS WILL WAY
OPINIONS ABSOLUTELY.
WHY YOU KNOW TOM I THINK IT IS I
WILL HAVID POINT I TWEETED I
FEEL HAMAS IS WING THE
PROPAGANDA WAR THE WAY YOU
DEFEAT THAT SHOWING AMERICANS
THE TRUTH OF WHAT